48 hours is investigating the kidnapping
of a Louisiana mother in a quiet
Suburban neighborhood in August of 2017
Shonda Handley was taken at gunpoint
from her own home in the middle of the
day how she survived may seem like a
miracle 48 Hours contributor and our
lead National correspondent David bagno
met with Hanley for her very first TV
interview and it shows us how the gut
feeling of an off-duty sheriff's deputy
likely saved her life
around 2 30 in the afternoon on August 6
2017 Shonda Hanley was at her home in
Lafayette Louisiana with her daughter
Isabella when the doorbell rang I went
to the door and it sees two men the two
men posing as delivery guys forced
themselves in with guns
he started to scream to get the F on the
floor and don't move they handcuffed me
in front like this
Isabella upstairs at the time rushed to
see what was going on I was just stunned
the two men took Shonda threw her in the
back of a white van and drove off
prosecutors Kenny a bear and Donald
connect these guys are heading out of
town with Sean Hanley in the back of
that van how often do Residential
kidnappings happen here very rare yeah
not very often at all
not long after sheriff's deputy Chad
Martin clocked out of work and headed
home he was unaware of shonda's
kidnapping 60 miles away
as I was traveling there was a wreck on
the interstate I got stopped behind a
white van I could kind of see the the
driver of the van was starting to get
nervous in the mirror he was looking at
me he decided to get into the shoulder
and speed off
and sit right with me so I got in behind
him I put my emergency lights sirens on
Martin followed the van as the driver
exited the interstate turned down a dirt
road
then got stuck in the mud
two men jumped out and took off running
when you approached the van you've got
your gun drawn yes sir I opened the rear
door of the van and in the van what I
thought was a mannequin moved
scared me startled me so I jumped back
and I shut the door
oh my God things aren't always what they
seem
oh
you're not gonna believe what happened
next
well the two men the two men jump out
the car yeah and they jump in the water
yeah and what happens next shocks
everyone
that's a good team that's a good time
Saturday night you got me hanging on I
don't even know where everywhere I was
in that scene right there like that off
duty office what made him though stop
the van because he said the guy looked
nervous so it's fascinating first of all
he's on his way home his wife's upset
that he's late because he's chronically
late and he saw the van drive on the
side of the road because the van saw him
in the rearview mirror and the driver
got nervous wow had it not been for that
I think Shonda Hanley would be dead
today do we have any idea motive yeah
Shonda has no connection to those guys
zero nil zero nil so here's the deal
her estranged husband ended up going on
trial accused of everything but the
question is how did the husband connect
with the guys who were driving the van
yeah and how did the guys drive in the
van know about the wife right look I
grew up in this area
women don't get kidnapped in broad
daylight out of their home and put in
the back of a vehicle and head down the
interstate 10. it just doesn't happen it
doesn't happen almost anywhere right I
mean it's not a commonplace thing no
matter what right this happened back in
2017 I remember when the 48 Hours
producers came to me I was in Puerto
Rico covering hurricane Maria yeah and
I'd even heard about it so I started
calling people I called like my high
school speech coaches like have you
heard of this Sean the Hanley case and
she's like oh yeah we heard about it so
does your 48 because we have lots of
questions David does this go 48 Hours
piece answer the questions like the
connection 100
motive yeah so the bottom line is the
estranged husband is in prison right and
loves to hear himself talk and wanted to
talk to us but the prison shut it down
she is the alleged Mastermind but how he
came to put it all together how he found
two men what he did by the way I'll give
you one more thing before we go okay
Shonda Hanley before the husband goes to
prison goes to their hunting camp in
Mississippi and she's looking at a
camera and she goes what's this and so
she always they start playing back the
camera and all of a sudden the husband
for months had been saying things and
the camera
all of it she calls the prosecutor she's
like you'll never believe what I just
found David this is such a good story
such a good tomorrow night 48 hours all
right we're booked up then all right
David thank you very much you can see
David's full report
on 48 hours tomorrow night at 10 9
Central here on CBS and streaming on
Paramount Plus